[Musique]
ce n'était qu'une question de temps
les stratégies d'hameçonnage et les
arnaques en tout genre basé sur la copie
19 se multiplient en ce moment sur le
web
méfiez-vous un exemple à retenir des
courriels menaçants d'infecter toute
votre famille aux nouveaux camps à virus
si vous n'envoyez pas une somme d'argent
à l'expéditeur
j'ai effectué chaque membre de votre
famille avec le corona virus gâcher
complètement votre vie c'est ce qu'ont
pu lire entre autres dans ce courriel
qui circulent en ce moment et qui
exigent un paiement urgent par crypto
monnaie ça c'est une stratégie connue
d'extorsion comme le nôtre notre
collaborateur nicolas de rosa dans son
article habituellement les arnaqueurs
même menace de rendre publiques des
images explicites ou les informations
personnelles du récipiendaire du
courriel si aucun paiement est effectué
en voyant la pandémie arrive et
évidemment les arnaqueurs un peu partout
ont flairé la bonne affaire
étendu leur piège une occasion en or
pour les escrocs du web
autre exemple de stratagèmes frauduleux
le voici les faux sites web
un chercheur en cybersécurité connu sous
le pseudonyme dostie frêche dit avoir
répertorié entre le 14 et le 18 mars
plus de 3600 nouveau nom de domaine où
figure le terme coronavirus un de ses
sites répertoriés se fait passer pour l'
agence de la santé publique du canada
imaginé et incite les gens à télécharger
un fichier malveillant déguisé en
lettres de l'hygiéniste en chef du pays
et sachez que les maliciels liés à la
commune de 19 existe aussi sous forme
d'applications frauduleuses l'une
d'entre elles se nomment kobe 19 sera
que et prétend offrir un suivi des
personnes infectées par le coran navire
situé à proximité
en réalité cette appli prend plutôt en
otage le téléphone des victimes
en échange et oui d'une rançon faux
sites web fausse application courriel
d'extorsion pour bien vous protéger
contre ce type de fraude
je vous invite à consulter les sites web
du centre antifraude du canada est aussi
le site web du centre canadien pour la
cybersécurité et n'oubliez pas de
consulter les articles signés nicolas de
rosa sur la page web des décrypteurs
n'oublie pas nous écrire aussi
décrypteurs au pluriel à commerce
el radio tu tirais canada.ca on va
tenter de répondre à toutes vos
questions
salut